what's going on my name is Harrison if
you didn't know I have a YouTube channel
an Associated website where I teach
about 800 free Python tutorials on a
huge variety of topics just about
anything you could want early on in my
career for Python I wanted to find some
high quality Python apparel and I was
pretty laid down and found that
basically there is none so I did what
anyone would do I used my wife's
embroidery machine and I made my own
pretty quickly though people were asking
hey where did you get that jacket I
wasn't really trying to start a business
out of it or anything but I did wear it
in some of the videos just because it's
the jacket I like to wear and and that
basically brings us to here now in order
for me to be able to actually sell
Python apparel I need to be able to at
least make that first purchase in bulk
but also I need to have some sort of
prior knowledge of the spread of sizes
of Python jackets let's say or shirts or
anything else that I might sell I need
to know a little bit of prior
information as far as what I actually
need to order before I go order let's
say a hundred hoodies only to find out
I'm only selling one size or something
like that so if you'd like to make this
a thing if you'd like to show your love
for Python you want to support the free
education on Python programming net in
the YouTube channel and you want to
support the Python Software Foundation
10% of all sales including the ones
through this campaign go to the Python
Software Foundation and you want to look
cool in the process you can support this
campaign to visit the campaign you can
either click here if you have
annotations on or you can view a link in
the description and support us that way
so help spread the word of the campaign
and I'll see you in the next tutorial